Thaïlande Bangkok la capitale il est
9h30 du matin les voitures roulent par
choc contre pare-choc depuis déjà trois
heures et ici cela n'a rien
d'exceptionnel 5 jours sur 7 il est
pratiquement impossible de circuler dans
la capitale thaïlandaise un cauchemar
pour les habitants de la ville un
casse-tête permanent pour ses motards
qui dépendent directement du roi de
Thaïlande leur job est unique au monde
oui récupérer une femme enceinte dans un
taxi où ça
ouais la femme enceinte est bloquée dans
le centre-ville à peine 5 km de
l'hôpital le plus proche lorsque les
motards rejoignent le taxi pour
l'escorter la jeune femme a déjà perdu
les eaux on arrive par le pont par le
pont ça roule bien par là
effectivement les motards ont opté pour
le bon trajet mais à 300 mètres de
l'hôpital un nouveau bouchon et wazana
est donc déjà en train d'accoucher dans
le taxi les policiers décident alors
d'intervenir directement à la sortie de
la voie express
[Musique]
et pendant que certains policiers jouent
les accoucheurs d'autres font circuler
les curieux car l'embouteillage risque
de s'aggraver
le bébé est toujours relié à sa mère
quand le convoi redémarre il faudra
encore 10 bonnes minutes avant
d'atteindre l'hôpital et pouvoir enfin
couper le cordon ombilical
c'est un garçon Dang pèse quatre kilos
le 9e dans la carrière de l'officier
s'annonc et le cinquième pour wazana le
premier qu'elle met au monde dans un
taxi un nouveau miracle et ce n'est pas
le premier
à Bangkok sauver des femmes enceintes et
devenu un job à temps plein pour les
membres de l'unité royale d'intervention
de la police routière en tout 200
policiers volontaires sachailles
l'instructeur a déjà 30 accouchements à
son actif
cette petite poire rouge on la presse
pour aider le bébé à respirer
on la met dans le nez et on relâche pour
retirer toutes les glaires du nouveau-né
[Applaudissements]
on jette quand le nez est sec on le voit
car la bouche du bébé est bien nette
on va donc enrouler le bébé dans l'ange
on le prend dans ses mains et on la
porte à la mer ensuite il faut
accompagner mère-enfant vers le médecin
le plus proche c'est bien ça professeur
oui tout à fait
l'entraînement indispensable car l'unité
intervient plus de 10 fois par semaine à
leur tableau de chasse chaque année plus
de 200 bébés nés dans les embouteillages
finalement les motards du roi sont
devenus aujourd'hui plus sage-femmes que
policiers la création de cette unité a
été décidée par le roi de Thaïlande en
personne il y a 10 ans à la suite d'une
série d'accouchements malheureux dans
les embouteillages toujours mais aussi
pour donner une meilleure image de la
police
ce matin l'officier s'an-ongle est venu
prendre des nouvelles de wazana la
tradition veut qu’un policier accoucheur
devienne automatiquement le parrain d'un
bébé né dans les bouchons et ce jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie
bonjour voici des petits cadeaux et
quelques couches
le bébé d'or
attention attention avec la moustiquaire
c'est un peu dangereux
donc ça veut dire célèbre il est connu
dans tout le pays alors
c'est lui qui t'a mis au monde
je souhaite que ce petit devienne un
policier comme nous
qu'on ressent à aider les autres
bonne chance et portez-vous bien
nous sommes aux États-Unis états du
Wisconsin tandis que les bébés
thaïlandais poussent leur premier cri
dans les embouteillages à quelques
milliers de kilomètres de là de faux
bébé robots finissent d'être
confectionné en usine de faux bébés mais
qui n'ont presque rien à envier au vrai
[Musique]
the baby le bébé a plusieurs fonctions
entre autres un coup qui doit être
impérativement maintenu sinon il se met
automatiquement à pleurer
il simule la prise du biberon
fleur pour être changé
c'est bourré d'électronique le bébé
pleure en fonction de ce qu'il réclame
lorsqu'il a faim lorsqu'il faut le
lancer lorsqu'il faut le verser parfois
même il pleure sans raison et vous ne
savez pas pourquoi
va changer leur vie
c'est quelque chose dont on va reparler
premier cours d'éducation sexuelle pour
ses élèves d'une classe de 4e une
demi-heure pendant laquelle l'accent est
mis principalement sur la morale pas un
mot ou presque n'est prononcé sur les
méthodes contraceptives
pour prévenir les grossesses
d'adolescentes l'abstinence reste la
meilleure méthode malheureusement
certains ados ont des rapports sexuels
nous savons bien sûr que l'utilisation
d'un préservatif d'un spermicide est une
autre solution
mais je préfère les inciter à réfléchir
sur l'impact que pourrait provoquer la
naissance d'un enfant sur leur avenir
ça c'est le cerveau du bébé
entre l'élève et le bébé c'est une sorte
de boîte noire
le cerveau enregistre tout les pleurs
la position de l'enfant la façon dont il
est porté si les violemment secoué tout
ça s'est enregistré s'il est bien traité
c'est aussi enregistré
en fait tous les comportements de
l'adolescent envers le bébé sont gardés
en mémoire
je pense que ton bébé pèse 3 kilos et
demi
pour le weekend un bracelet magnétique
et une clé vont permettre aux jeunes
parents d'établir un contact
électronique permanent avec leur bébé
le tien fait un peu plus de 3 kilos
je vous demande de tenir à jour un
carnet de bord
vous noterez comment se comporte votre
bébé
comment vous vous vivez cette expérience
et je vous demande de mettre en avant au
moins trois situations qui vous ont
marqué lorsque vous reviendrez lundi
prochain
ce sont les garçons qui mettent les
filles enceintes
ils doivent donc savoir aussi ce que
c'est que de s'occuper d'un enfant
c'est comme si j'avais un vrai bébé
pas c'est ma responsabilité ils seront
là près de moi mais ils ne s'occuperont
pas du bébé il ne seront pas les parents
c'est à moins d'être la mère comme si
c'était vraiment mon bébé
tu es mignonne
je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir des
enfants peut-être plus tard quand je
serai plus vieille mais pas maintenant
la t'inquiète ça va m'empêcher de faire
des tas de choses
j'avais une fête par exemple ce soir
mais je me suis aperçue que ce ne serait
pas malin de l'emmener à cause du bruit
du monde
donc je n'irai pas
chaque fois que son bébé pleure Zac
dispose de moins de 2 minutes pour
signaler à l'ordinateur qu'il a entendu
les cris à lui de comprendre ce que
réclame son enfant
je pense qu'il faut que je le change
tu penses vraiment que tu changerais un
vrai bébé comme ça par terre dans la rue
je pense pas mais là sur la couverture
il fait chaud
si je n'avais pas cette couverture là ce
serait une autre histoire
si j'étais sur un trottoir au milieu de
nulle part là j'aurais vraiment un
problème
[Musique]
c'est une nuit d'enfer pour Zac c'est la
troisième fois que son fils le réveille
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre je crois que je ne suis
pas prêt d'avoir un enfant et d'en
assumer la responsabilité avant
longtemps
dans la pièce d'à côté la mère de Zac et
toute la famille participent malgré elle
à l'expérience
je pense que c'est un bon programme ce
qui me tracasse un peu c'est d'avoir
observé quelques adolescents qui n'ont
vu que le côté marrant des choses c'est
sympa de changer les vêtements
j'espère que cela ne transmettra pas de
simulation de jours 16 heures et 41
minutes
élève 77
ça indique le nombre de fois où tu t'es
occupé de lui
baby-sitter 0 tu n'en as pas eu besoin
il fait nourriture 35
durant ces 35 fois une seule fois tu as
laissé ton bébé pleurer pendant plus de
2 minutes
c'est très bien
je trouve que c'est pas si mal que ça
est-ce que tu aimerais que je le rallume
pour que tu t'en occupes tous les jours
après les cours
que tu le gardes chaque jour après
l'école que tu le gardes la nuit et que
tu le ramènes tous les matins
non
pourquoi ça ne te dit rien
non parce que ça m'empêche de faire
autre chose